good afternoon
and welcome to washington national
cathedral my name is randy hollarth
and i am the dean of the cathedral and
on behalf of bishop mary and buddy and
all of us who
serve this wonderful institution it's
our pleasure to have you here with us
for this special event
this cathedral is a house of prayer for
all people and i am honored
to stand this afternoon with many of our
brothers
and sisters from a variety of different
faith traditions our various traditions
as unique and special as they are have
numerous things in common
and none more so than what is commonly
called
the golden rule whether it's expressed
as
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you
or that which you want for yourself seek
for mankind or love
your neighbor as yourself this ethic
of mutual regard and reciprocity is
fundamental
to the vast majority of faith traditions
as such what could be more appropriate
than for us to gather today
and encourage all people especially
people of faith
to make sure that they get vaccinated
not only to protect themselves from
covid19 but more importantly to help
protect
others from this terrible disease by
increasing the levels of immunity within
the population and by helping to slow
the mutations of this virus that have
caused so many
even more infectious variants
as people of faith who are called to
love and care for our neighbors we
should be leading the way
in this effort and so we stand together
or
sit together as the point may be
to send a clear message that these
vaccines
are a great blessing
they are a great blessing
and we need to take advantage of that
blessing
and we need to encourage others to do
the same
so thank you for being with us and in a
few minutes we'll have
some brief remarks from some special
guests that i would like to thank for
being here and introduced to you
the first is melissa rogers who is the
executive director of the white house
office
of faith-based and neighborhood
partnerships
so glad she's with us dr
ileso perez estable who's director of
nih's national institute on minority
health
and health disparities dr francis
collins
the director of nih and the man who
needs no introduction
dr anthony fauci the director of the
national institute
of allergy and infectious disease i want
to thank those
our special guests for being with us
thank you so much
[Applause]
again we're so thrilled that you're here
with us and thanks to all the
jurisdictions who have come
and to support this event and to give
vaccines
it's seems to me to be an incredible
blessing from god that we were able to
get all of this together so thank you
now i'll turn this over to the man who
not only thought of today's event
but whose very hard work made it
possible the reverend dr
leonard hamlin who is our cathedral's
canon missioner
leonard
thank you over the past
year words such as community spirit
compassion justice
and a host of other words have been
elevated in our vocabularies
words are significant but they have
power
only when they're connected to our
actions
this evening we have gathered in this
space
recognizing the challenge of this moment
but we've come together embracing the
opportunities that are in front of us
it is important that we encourage
everyone who is able to get
vaccinated faith leaders
medical chiefs managers regional
officials
are all here that we might not be
defined by the demographics
that often divide us but we are here
embracing the truth that unites us
a truth that is probably characterized
best in words that i've always heard
growing up
that because of our faith the task ahead
of us
is not as great as the power that is
behind us
and so i remind us on today of the words
of robert frost that said two roads
diverged in a wood
and i took the one less traveled by
and that has made the difference
today we have come together that we
might make a difference in the moment
in which lives are at stake
and we recognize today that everyone
needs to be counted and so
the words of one who has was lifted here
years ago
that we all know well it is true as
martin luther king jr said
in a real sense all life is
interrelated all men
are caught in an inescapable network of
mutuality
tied in a single garment of destiny what
affects one
directly affects all indirectly
we are all in this together and so i'm
thankful today to recognize
the faces that are on the platform
that are representing the medical
community
faith community as well as even the
educational community
and on this day i'd like to recognize
and say thank you
to county executive mark elrich
the county executive of montgomery
county maryland
i'd like to say thank you to george dr
george askew
deputy chief administration officer for
health and human
services education prince george's
county maryland
dr joseph wright who is vice president
and chief medical officer
of the university of maryland capital
health region
dr anker shah principal
senior deputy director district of
columbia
department of health i'd like to give a
special thanks to the reverend thomas
bowen
the mayor's office of religious affairs
of the district of columbia
who did a lot of heavy lifting with me
in this moment
and reaching around to help the
cathedral to live its mission
the washington national cathedral
i'd like to say thank you to dr reuben
varkeys public health director of
arlington county virginia
councilman john taylor chapman of
alexandria city council
dr hugh mighty dean of howard university
college of medicine
and vice president of clinical affairs
dr shelly mcdonald pickett pinkett
who is the interim chair of internal
medicine and chief medical officer
of howard university hospital doc
michael crawford associate dean of
strategy
outreach and innovation of howard
university
you've heard many names as well as
different communities represented but
today we come as one
because the only way to achieve success
in this moment is by our reaching across
and working together
there is an old african proverb that
says if you want to go fast
go alone but if you want to go far
go together today we go together
good evening everyone i'd like to thank
national cathedral for organizing this
terrific event tonight and for inviting
us to participate
this is one great example of a
partnership
between government and faith-based
organizations
and as president biden has recognized
faith-based organizations can play
key roles in helping americans get
vaccinated
let me mention just a few reasons
government should work with interested
religious leaders and faith-based
organizations
on vaccination efforts first
houses of worship are pervasive and
familiar to many americans
countless americans are far more
comfortable
getting their shot in a house of worship
than in a pharmacy or a doctor's office
second religious figures are among the
most trusted community leaders
so seeing congregational leaders get
vaccinated first
can relieve anxieties and fears
the third reason why government and
faith-based organizations should work
together
in this task is that faith-based
organizations are often
highly skilled at reaching under-served
people
indeed congregational leaders haven't
simply turned over
their buildings for use as vaccination
sites they're also manning the phones to
get
people vaccinated they're providing
transportation to vaccination sites and
doing so many other things to make this
task
one that is doable for everyone
fourth the vast majority of religious
leaders
are enthusiastic about helping the
country get vaccinated
many clergy have emphasized for example
that getting the vaccine
is a way of loving our neighbors
fifth governmental partnerships with
faith leaders to promote public health
are permitted
not prohibited by our constitution
indeed partnerships with diverse faith
communities can be a
powerful affirmation of our pluralism
and our unity across our differences in
background
and belief so in sum governmental
partnerships with faith-based
organizations
can and should be part of the solution
to the covet 19 challenge
as president biden has so often said
there's nothing that americans can't do
when we do it together thank you
good afternoon i'm francis collins the
director of the national institutes of
health
which we sometimes like to
call the national institutes of hope and
i'm certainly here in a hopeful
way today looking up at that stained
glass window in the twilight
reminded that i have a copy of that
hanging in my window in my home office
where i've essentially been a hermit for
the last 12 months
trying to manage the largest supporter
of biomedical research in the world
and i'm honored to be in this sacred
space again with these
leaders of multiple faiths
let us all recognize that the last year
has been one of struggle
and of lament for all of us
and yet we now have reasons for hope
as a believer and a scientist
i can see the opportunity to use the
tools of science
as a chance to be part of god's plan for
healing
the vaccines have in many ways for many
people been an
answer to prayer they are safe and
effective beyond
what we had a right to expect
and yet they will not help people by
sitting on the shelf
they need to be injected into the arms
of those who need them
unfortunately many who could most
benefit
because they are at highest risk of
serious and even
life-threatening infections are still
holding back
worried about stories they hear
skeptical unimpressed by how
government has previously shown interest
in their medical care
skeptical the church can play a
leading role by educating modeling
and encouraging that there is nothing to
fear here and there's much
to be gained that's what we are here to
do today
houses of worship are houses of hope
here on this hill the national cathedral
represents that
and yes we all need hope at this time
but hope alone is not a strategy
today all of you are putting hope into
action
hope for an end to the terrible
suffering and loss of life from covet
19.
hope for an end to the economic
devastation it has caused
hope that the vaccine can not only
protect you
but also if we do this together your
family
your friends your community your nation
your whole world this is a love your
neighbor opportunity
to spread that hope far and wide
the jewish tradition has a metaphor
about community the community is like a
ship
but if there's a hole in the lower hold
of the ship
one does not say only the lower hold has
a hole in it
rather all must recognize the risk of
sinking
so everyone works to repair that breach
in order for us to get through this
challenge of cobat 19
we must work together to repair any
breaches that might allow that virus to
continue
its terrible tragedy around us
and that means all of us working
together so my deepest thanks to all who
have gathered here all who are listening
the other remarkable people on the
platform for joining in this plan
to repair any breaches in our ship of
vaccine healing
thank you very much
good evening my name is tony fauci and
i'm the director of the national
institutes of allergy and
infectious diseases at the national
institutes
of health i first wanted to underscore
all the important points
that were made by my colleague and
friend dr francis collins
but i also like to spend my couple of
minutes
talking to you a little bit about the
facts
and some of the fiction associated with
vaccines
how do these vaccines work i often get
asked that question by people
who understandably want to learn more
about what it is that's being injected
into their arm
vaccines that we have for covert 19
all have one thing in common it takes
a single protein of the virus
not the whole virus and that protein
gets expressed in different ways
depending upon
what particular vaccine platform
that is being used in the vaccine
that you will have some have a little
snippet of
messenger rna that codes for the protein
the spike protein on the virus others
are little harmless viruses that have
the dna for that spike protein
that when you inject it in it makes the
protein
the body thinks that it's the virus
but it's not the virus it's a harmless
protein component of the virus
so that when the body sees that it
thinks it's the virus
and it makes a very powerful immune
response
to protect you for when you do get
exposed
to the virus so how do we know these
vaccines
work we know they work
because they've been tested in tens of
thousands of individuals
30 000 people in the modernity trial
four thousand people in the fisa trial
and forty thousand people in the johnson
and johnson or jnj
trial and there's more to come because
there are also more vaccine candidates
that we're evaluating
a common question that we get asked
is how can you be sure that it's
actually safe and effective and the
answer is
because they've been tested in tens of
thousands of people and the decision
about whether it works namely is safe
and effective
is not made by the administration
not made by the congress not made by the
pharmaceutical company
it's made by an independent group
of scientists ethicists
statisticians who look at the data
and in an independent manner decide
whether it is safe and effective
then that data goes to the fda
whose career scientists look at it
and in association with their own
advisory committee
make a decision whether or not it should
be administered
to all of us myself included
so the answer is that the process
is both independent and transparent
another important question is but you've
been telling us
that it takes years to make a vaccine
how could you possibly have a vaccine
when you just knew the virus was a new
virus in january of 2020
and 11 months later you're injecting a
vaccine
into our arms and the reason is
the extraordinary scientific advances
that have taken place decades before
january 2020
in other words things didn't start on
january
10 2020 they started
decades before by large numbers of
scientists
who were working their way to the point
where we could actually have this
vaccine
let me close by making a couple of
comments about
some of the myths about this particular
vaccine that we can understand how
people
can have these kinds of false rumors but
let's address them
we often get asked can you get covert 19
from the vaccine as i just told you
the vaccine is a small component
of the virus it's not the virus itself
so it is impossible to get covert 19
from the vaccine secondly
does it get into my dna it is
biologically impossible
for that to happen can it make me
sterile
there is no biological reason at all to
think
that that would happen and already tens
of thousands of people
have received the vaccine with no
significant adverse events
and then the one that's particularly
interesting to me
is that no neither i and i believe i can
speak for bill gates
have put a chip into the virus when it
gets injected in here that might seem
ludicrous
but there really are things as
ridiculous as
that that are being circulated
so i want you all to realize
that this particular process is very
well controlled with the highest
standard of ethics so i want to close
by thanking all of the people who've
been vaccinated
as well as those who plan to get
vaccinated because what you're doing
is not only protecting yourselves
your families and your communities but
you're being part of the
important process of ending this
terrible pandemic
that has essentially immobilized our
country
and the world for the last year we will
get through this
and we will get through it by
vaccination
thank you
good afternoon my name is eliseo perez
establi
i'm the director of the national
institute on minority health and health
disparities
and it is a real honor to be here to
talk to you today
for a few couple of minutes i recently
read that the washington cathedral
was the place where dr martin luther
king jr
gave his last sunday sermon just a few
days
before he was assassinated in memphis so
i thought that was fitting for us to be
here today
working to support and encourage all of
our communities
all of our communities of color to do
what we can do
to be safe and help end this pandemic
that has devastated so many so many
families
in this country and in the globe
today disparities have been shown by
covert 19.
this pandemic has illustrated inequities
in our society
that we knew about for decades but
really have
been been really put in contrast
in a rapid way in just a year
over 500 000 americans have died
over 50 percent of all cases and almost
half of all deaths
are in persons of african-american
latino or hispanic background
american indian and pacific islanders
now much has been said about well the
risk is greater because there's more
disease more diabetes more more obesity
more heart disease but the reality is
that the infections are more likely
because people live in more crowded
conditions they work in jobs that do not
do not allow the privilege
of teleworking they cannot self-isolated
home
because the two families three
generations
one bathroom these are just structural
realities
of this of the population in addition
many do not have computers depend on
their cell phone
for access to information and therefore
reaching this population
has become more of a challenge so this
risk
of economic inequality
educational inequality and occupational
differences
is what leads to these disparities
now at nih nimhd and
other institutes at nih our response has
been that we need to address this by
connecting with our communities
we have established a program called
community engaged
against covet 19 alliance or seal
for short with my colleague dr gary
gibbons who could not be here today
from the national national heart and
lung and blood institute
now dr fauci laid out all this
misinformation that's circulating out
there and there
is not uh it is everywhere all
communities are exposed to this
um our response is we need to address
this misinformation directly
with facts with simple facts not jargon
based on data based on science and to
promote
trust in science we have lost this we
have not been ahead of
this misinformation and it's time that
we started to do more of that
both in terms of the infection of how
it's transmitted
but also on the vaccine issue once it is
out and we have certainly focused on
that
this trust needs to be delivered by
trusted messengers
and you as faith-based leaders of all
denominations
are really critical in this effort much
like
local physicians nurses other health
care workers
and other trusted leaders in our
communities
we have a lot of faith that our seal
initiative
will make a difference in the states
that we have launched it
and we continue to work on expanding it
and turn towards vaccine uptake
so really creating the structures to
promote
make it easy for people to get
vaccinated such as
an event like this and other houses of
worship opening up
to um to being vaccinated
now i want to just close by saying that
i'm confident that this effort is going
to make a difference
i think all of us are eager uh to be
able to again
see our loved ones and share with people
in person
not zoom i was vaccinated myself
a little over two weeks ago got my
second shot i went through the dc
vaccine website it wasn't easy but i got
it done
and i think the easier we can make it as
we get more and more people
vaccinated the better we'll be thanks
everyone for
being here for organizing this
it really is important for all of us to
be together
to work towards a better future thank
you
hello i'm marianne buddy bishop of the
episcopal diocese of washington
after hearing such important remarks
from
our scientific and medical and
governmental communities
and in the presence of such esteemed
colleagues
in faith i'm honored to close this
portion of our gathering in prayer
may we begin by simply calling to mind
all those we've lost
and those who suffer
and we thank you gracious god for all
who have worked so tirelessly
to bring the scourge of covet 19 in this
land and around the world
to an end we lament
the inequities and the injustices that
have caused
so many to suffer needlessly
and we pray that this effort along with
others will help
overcome some of the disparities that
have divided us
let this vaccination effort be our
our marking event to create justice in
our society and our health care system
and to restore the trust that is so
needed for us to move forward
most of our gracious juan may those who
have dared to go first be
followed by those who go second and
followed by those who go third
fourth and fifth so that we might by
our um our example of following courage
might encourage others to be brave and
do the thing that
scares us but also allows us to be part
of this great journey toward restored
life
all this we ask in the gracious name of
god
amen
thank you
thank you all very much
we're going to move now row by rows
that's also going to follow
dean hollerath off the platform row by
row
and then give the cameras the time to
adjust and then we'll walk through
the table
already
you